this week on brian ross investigates the
russian oligarchs their yachts mansions
and billion-dollar bank accounts now
targeted
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
in the wake of the invasion of ukraine
putin's cronies being forced to decide
abandon him
face the loss of their wealth plus a new
alarm sounding for america's
firefighters over a chemical used in
their turnout gear there's a strong
correlation between the c8 form of this
chemical and two types of cancer
testicular cancer kidney cancer we're
joined by the president of the
international association of
firefighters this must feel like a great
betrayal to be furnished this gear only
to learn that it's causing a potential
cancer
in my opinion it's led to countless
deaths amongst firefighters at a young
age
and we are committed to taking this
fight on
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of
mediaheight the fact is that
he barely knew where ukraine was
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague here at law and
crime rhonda schwartz and rhonda we
begin tonight with a look at putin's
oligarchs the
multi-multi-billionaires who have been
crucial to vladimir putin's rise to
power in russia they are now in the
crosshairs of the u.s and europe as part
of the sweeping economic sanctions being
imposed in the wake of russia's brutal
and unprovoked invasion of ukraine
rhonda
that's right brian u.s officials believe
if they can somehow deprive putin of
their support his power base will be
severely undermined
earlier this week president biden in his
state of the union address made it clear
that these oligarchs have now become
targets themselves
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i mean
the united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you or ill-begotten
gains and tonight
i'm announcing that we will join our
allies in closing off american air space
to all russian flights further isolating
russia and adding additional squeezed on
their economy
among the likely russian targets men
such as roman abramovich well known as
the owner of the chelsea soccer team in
britain with fabulous homes in london
and saint parts not to mention his
luxury yacht the solaris and his
apparent friendship with members of the
trump family the wall street journal
reporting this week that he's trying to
sell the soccer team for some three to
four billion dollars pledging to give
the proceeds to war victims in ukraine
and there's al-ashar uzmanov the
one-time owner of the arsenal soccer
team in the uk with mansions and villas
across europe and his own super yacht
the 512-foot dill bar to get a better
understanding of whether these efforts
to sanction them will have any effect
we're joined by professor louise shelley
the founder of the terrorism
transnational crime and corruption
center at george mason university who
specializes in the former soviet union
and by spencer woodman who has led the
reporting on this issue for the
international consortium of
investigative journalists thank you both
for being here professor sean let me
start with you there are reports already
that one of the so-called oligarchs oleg
daras paska has called on putin to stop
the bloodshed so is even just the threat
of the sanctions enough to begin to work
on them one needs to be careful of what
gary poshka has said
he has said that
war should stop he has not criticized
putin for
leading this attack on ukraine so
therefore he's trying to protect himself
and do you think these uh proposed
sanctions will have any impact are they
going to start
abandoning their friend mr putin
not quite yet we have to make these
sanctions work and unfortunately there
are lots of barriers at the moment to
getting at their assets and even to
finding them because a boat a plane
cannot easily be hidden but millions if
not billions are hidden in real estate
where we don't know who the real owners
are
and spencer whitman that's been one of
your focuses the hidden wealth of all
these oligarchs there are literally
hundreds of them
there are and it's i mean
as uh
as a reporter covering this i
spend long days trying to get beneath
the layers of secrecy that a lot of
these oligarchs have um put in the way
of
any sort of public scrutiny or
understanding
of their assets um i think the uh us
treasury just announced uh uh uh
interagency task force um
to try to get to to not only you know uh
enforce these sanctions but actually
figure out how to get beneath some of
these um some of these the various
layers of assets that the oligarchs use
um in order to um to hide their wealth
and professor shelly a question for you
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
if it's difficult legally to enforce
these sanctions to go after these
oligarchs what about in the court of
public opinion is this the end of the
lifestyles of the rich and famous
i don't think we're there yet they have
so much of their money and their yachts
in offshore locales
so they're heading their boats off and
yachts off to the maldives they're in
places that are out of reach
the problem and is to make sure that
they're not enjoying their wealth
in the u.s but going after and seizing
these assets is a whole lot more
difficult than it suggests
and i think as we
talked ab just mentioned this task force
this is a governmental task force but
the information that we need
sits in
civil society with journalists with
researchers it needs to be a whole of
society approach to go after this
spencer woodman some of your reporting
has been on the hidden money including
this cellist who putin apparently uses
yeah so that probably one of putin's
most well-known
uh
proxies that is someone who
holds great amounts of wealth
for him but not in his name
is um
a guy named sergey roll dugan who's a
childhood friend of putin uh and he was
a classical cellist in st petersburg
um
the panama papers revealed that role
dugan was receiving literally billions
of dollars in payments
um in uh
amassing tremendous unexplained wealth
um and the reporting heavily suggests
that this wealth was being held for
vladimir putin royal dugan was just for
the first time sanctioned by the eu on
monday
even though this reporting has existed
for
several years now right and professor
shelly what's the calculation that these
oligarchs have to make as the threat of
sanctions is levied on them in terms of
staying loyal with putin or not
at the moment
they're
they're playing both sides
not all of them a few of them are
attacking the war but not attacking
putin and i think it's going to take a
lot more time for these oligarchs to
turn on him because they have families
they have enormous business wealth in in
russia
and hadarkovsky who turned on putin a
long time ago
wound up losing his prime properties
he was criminally investigated and sent
to siberia to serve a long time in a
labor camp so it's clear what the costs
are of crossing putin
and spencer woodman how about putin
himself talk about oligarchs he said to
be one of if not the wealthiest man in
the world
yeah and you know uh
untangling his wealth has been just so
difficult for both um
journalists and
uh people in government um
you know you can sanction him which is a
novel and interesting thing to do
but the meaningfulness of that is going
to be limited
if you don't know where his wealth is
and exactly who's holding it
all right well spencer woodman and
professor shelly thank you so much for
being with us here tonight
thank you for having us
thanks ryan you bet up next an urgent
alarm for america's firefighters could
the chemical in their turnout gear be
putting them at risk for cancer
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
we turn now to new development to the
story we've been closely following here
concern over the chemicals used to
waterproof the turnout gear worn by
america's firefighters now the
international association of
firefighters has decided to break off
its relationships and reject any future
funding from any company using those
chemicals and offering full support for
a series of lawsuits filed on behalf of
firefighters claiming their cancers were
caused by those very chemicals
america's firefighters are responding to
a new kind of alarm that could put them
at risk
about a class of chemicals that's been
used for years to waterproof what's
known as their turnout gear
it's added to the turnout gear to keep
them dry
when a firefighter is actively using a
hose they get wet
if you are carrying 60 pounds of gear
already adding 40 extra pounds of water
weight when you get wet is a real
it cuts down the
time that a firefighter can be active on
scene but professor graham peasley at
notre dame university who's been
studying the turnout gear used by fire
departments across the country says the
chemical used most widely until recently
known by its shorthand c8 presents its
own risk to firefighters
there's a strong correlation between the
c8 form of this chemical and two types
of cancer testicular cancer and kidney
cancer
it's the same class of chemicals in the
foam used by firefighters to put out
certain kinds of fires
it's all led to a series of lawsuits and
a warning now from the international
association of firefighters
and we're joined now by ed kelly who's
the president of the international
association of firefighters mr kelly
thank you so much for being with us
brian thank you and thank you for
shedding light on this very important
subject
you say it's no coincidence that there's
increased rates of cancer among
firefighters
well even going back to for decades
we've known that the exposures that we
endure when we respond to fires when
burning materials are off-gassing expose
us to carcinogens and lead to higher
rates of cancer what is a new revelation
is that our actual personal protective
equipment our bunker gear is actually
infused with carcinogens that we now
know we're re-exposing ourselves time
and time again so this is a new uh
threat that has emerged new reality
of how we're being exposed to these
carcinogens
you also say that the companies that
sell this gear with this chemical are
engaged in a public deception
what do you mean yeah we we would really
like to know
when these companies knew that these
carcinogens were exposing us
and what did they do about it
and i can tell you from our end we know
that they've com they've denied any
wrongdoing
so for your firefighter members this
must feel like a great betrayal to be
furnished this gear only to learn that
it's causing a potential cancer
in my opinion it's led to countless
deaths amongst firefighters at a young
age
and we are committed to taking this
fight on uh our members spoke loud and
clear at our convention we don't want to
be in bed with any chemical companies
and when it comes to you know these
chemical companies and what they've told
us
we're actively pursuing congressional
hearings to bring people before congress
to find out what they knew when they
knew it and what did they do about it
because our members deserve answers and
our families of our fallen deserve
answers it was the case of a
massachusetts firefighter paul cotter
that helped to spur the research i was
diagnosed with prostate cancer
in
october of 2014.
i had
treatment
surgery early in 15 and uh
had to retire
from a job at any point when you were
serving as a fire lieutenant on the
force there did you have any kind of
warning that there was this potential
harm from the turnout gear the chemicals
used to coat it
no none at all
none at all uh
no one ever no one ever thought about
the gears
being dangerous
we wore it
shopping we wore it sitting around in
the kitchen
um
you know it was our safety net
idea
it was only after cotter's cancer
diagnosis when his wife diane began to
do her own research and contacted the
notre dame professor that he learned of
the potential risk
i was pissed
and as a lot of firefighters
are in the same boat that i am
it led diane to become a champion in the
cause to investigate the use of the
chemicals in firefighters turnout gear
it changed everything brian when i tell
you it changed everything believe me
you don't want that cancer diagnosis
i get very emotional speaking about it
because he was
a fireman's firefighter
so even now five years later it's
difficult to talk about this is a
epic
disaster as far as we're concerned we
call it the greatest deception ever no
direct link has been proven between the
chemicals used on the turnout gear and
any specific firefighter's cancer
diagnosis but a growing number of
firefighters are demanding answers
meanwhile your members have to put on
that turnout gear every day they respond
to a fire
that's true
that's true and uh it's a um
it's a painful
uh reality of of the situation that
we're in
so finally what's your message to your
firefighter members
that we're taking this fight head on and
we're not going to back down to anybody
and then we'll together we're going to
find a solution to this problem
all right ed kelly president of the
international association of
firefighters thank you so much for being
with us here this evening
brian thank you
the companies named in the lawsuit and
cited by the firefighters group have all
said they believe the chemicals were
safe when they used them and a number of
the companies say they no longer use the
chemicals in question
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
editors of mediaite and what they have
to say
you're watching brian ross investigates
the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and aiden
you've chosen as your winner this week
matthew chats at cnn for his exclusive
interview in the bunker with ukrainian
president zielinski
you sent your delegation to meet the
russians for talks
did anything substantial come out of
that is there any hope
as the world watches for diplomacy they
decided they decided
to begin to speak about this situation
and i want it i i really wanted and i
asked them so you have to speak first of
all you everybody has to
stop
stop fighting
and aiden this week that's the interview
everyone wanted
that's right and i think it's important
to note that uh matthew chance who's a
cnn foreign correspondent is one of the
few reporters who's also interviewed
vladimir putin the russian president um
now i think an overlooked storyline to
consider when conflict erupts abroad
just from a media perspective
is that the american news consumer is
watching war unfold through the
reporting of a select few correspondence
and so these kind of conflicts have the
ability to turn these reporters into
household names cnn's clarissa ward for
example was rightly celebrated for her
coverage of the withdrawal from
afghanistan um matthew chance who's also
a cnn reporter has been
on the ground in ukraine since before
the russian invasion and he's
distinguished himself with some urgent
and ubiquitous reporting uh about the
war he has been
stationed in kiev and reported on the
aftermath of bombings
he did a really memorable segment this
week from a bridge northwest of the
ukrainian capital
after a fierce gun fight between russian
and ukrainian troops
and then he landed this interview with
the ukrainian president of vladimir
zelinski
from his bunker in kiev
and it's kind of brave on the ground
reporting from around the world that
people look to cnn for um and i think
it's what incoming leadership of cnn has
said that they want from the network um
so cnn has a large group of reporters
and anchors stationed in ukraine
anderson cooper is now anchoring his
show live from ukraine
but it's really this reporting from
matthew chance that stood out this week
and as you point out the new leadership
is emphasizing news capital letters
instead of opinion that's right and you
know i think for the past couple years
cnn has gotten a reputation and not a
particularly good one uh for doing
leaning into uh opinion of the
anti-trump variety um that is cheap to
produce because all you have to do is
put a couple of pundits up on a panel
and have them uh fight it out um this
kind of reporting uh that cnn is really
known for and that does better than i'd
say any other network are reporting from
around the world with on-the-ground uh
reporters and correspondents is a lot
more expensive um it maybe doesn't get
the ratings that uh sort of punditry
does opinion punditry um but it's really
really valuable and i think it's what
people want cnn to be and it's certainly
with new leadership coming into cnn
wants the network to be done right and
this week's loser rob schmidt at newsmax
who tried to defend president trump as a
savior for ukraine and was shot down by
of all people john bolton
the fact is that he barely knew where
ukraine was he once asked john kelly his
second chief of staff if finland were a
part of russia
it's just not accurate to say that
trump's behavior somehow
deterred the russians
so rob schmidt got to come up with there
right so that's rob schmidt a newsmax
host and he pushed an argument that's
been pretty pervasive among trump
boosters in media that trump would have
somehow deterred putin from invading
ukraine because he showed resolve
that the current president uh president
joe biden has not um now we have no way
of knowing whether putin would have
invaded uh under a president trump had
he won the 2020 election that's a
hypothetical but newsmax the newsmax
host rob schmidt made that argument that
trump was tough on russia and that that
had a deterrent effect
um he said that in an interview with
john bolton who was the national
security adviser under donald trump and
he systematically rejected that argument
he said that trump did not have a tough
stance against putin and then all of the
um sanctions that were imposed on russia
by the trump administration trump
complained about and he said that they
were actually too tough on russia he
also noted as you saw in that clip that
trump barely knew where ukraine was and
even asked uh his chief of staff uh
whether uh finland were actually part of
russia so i i think it's a pretty pretty
systematic rejection of the idea it was
advanced by robert schmidt that trump
would have been tough all right aidan
thanks for watching that's our program
for tonight thanks for being with us
we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
you